- [Narrator] One night in March, 2023
in the Central African Republic,
security cameras captured a group
of men hurling Molotov
cocktails over the fence
of a brewing facility owned by
French multinational Castel,
one of the largest beverage
conglomerates in the world.
Western intelligence
agencies would later confirm
that The Wagner Group was
responsible for the attack
that destroyed a large portion
of the brewery's stock.
The arson wasn't a
random act of vandalism.
It was part of a larger war
for influence in Africa
between Russia and the West.
In the Central African Republic,
beer matters to Wagner
because French brands
have a large presence
in their former colony.
Since the 1990s,
Castel has produced a beer called MOCAF
in the Central African Republic.
The MOCAF Brewery has been
one of the largest employers
in the country's limited
industrial sector.
One year prior to the arson attack,
Wagner broke ground on a competing brewery
north of the capitol, Bangi.
They've rapidly scaled up
production and distribution
of their own beer brand
called Africa Ti L'Or,
which is sold as Russian.
Castel was able to keep
producing its MOCAF beer
throughout CAR's civil war,
but not without controversy.
In 2021, a report by the
investigative nonprofit group,
The Century detailed
how Castel protected its
business interests in CAR
by making cash payments to rebel groups
like the Union for Peace or UPC.
Castel did not respond
to requests for comment
but in the past,
they've denied these
payments were criminal
and that they fueled the conflict.
Using the details in the report,
Wagner saw an opportunity
to sell its narrative
about the role of the French
as exploitative colonizers in the country.
In January, 2023,
a group of social media
accounts began simultaneously
spreading the same message,
"Castel supports terrorism."
One meme spread by the campaign
depicted bottles of MOCAF
loaded into an assault
rifle with the message,
"Each bottle purchased is a
bullet in the gun of bandits."
Disinformation experts the
journal spoke to confirmed
these accounts were connected to Wagner
and said the campaign bears the hallmarks
of one of Wagner's online
influence operations.
Wagner's campaign also used offline means
of spreading this message
like billboards and flyers.
One flyer read "With each Castel purchase,
you fund the war and kill yourself."
The group also organized demonstrations
where protestors poured
out bottles of MOCAF
while holding signs about
Castel's support for armed groups.
The protests were amplified
by Wagner funded social media
accounts and news outlets.
Wagner used its existing
network of businesses
to supply, build, and staff its brewery.
Most Wagner businesses in CAR are centered
on natural resources like
gold, diamonds, and timber.
Africa Ti L'Or represents a shift
for Wagner into businesses
that engage with the public.
Selling Russian beer
to Central Africans
provides an opportunity
to sell a positive image for
Russia's role in the country.
Many of the same accounts that took part
in the campaign against
Castel now tout Africa Ti L'Or
as an alternative.
Representatives for
Wagner and Africa Ti L'Or
did not respond to requests for comment.
Wagner's message about Castel
mirrors its broader message
that the French exploited the country
and contributed to its violence,
and that Russia and
Wagner are here to help.
(man speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Across Africa,
Wagner has organized demonstrations
and social media campaigns,
promoting Russia as an alternative
to France and the West.
Since the attack, Castel has
continued to produce its beer
in CAR and Wagner's
future role in the country
appears to be in flux after
the death of its leader,
Yevgeni Prigozhin,
but their presence
remains deeply ingrained.